hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the world Fisher random
championship this is Game three
Fabiana karana versus Magnus Carlsen
karana took the game 1 then Magnus
retaliated in game 2 and now we're gonna
check out game 3 so now crossing gets
the black pieces in the first game
without further ado let's just check it
out and yes it would seem that whoever
plays with the white pieces gets the
white chair so it seemed that the
mystery has been solved now getting back
to the game Fabi opens with f4 we have
b6 by Magnus and it is already as a move
on that we have a completely new game
now I know some of you have been saying
in the comments that you don't enjoy
chess960 or facial random and yes III
kind of share your feelings but I don't
know it seems like it's just that I
already mentioned this when we were
covering some of some of the previous
games from the official random
championship that it's like we already
went through the opening phase and now
we have a completely new game we're
already very interesting stuff can
happen right from the beginning so it's
it's similar here and I don't know it is
very enjoyable when the players Castle
the positions pretty much look alike
look like any other chess game so just
wanted to mention that so getting back
to the game Fabi pushes f5 so her
pushing the point even further with f6
blocking the pawn and now Knight to b3
we have c5 are preparing the well sort
of fianchetto both bishops on the Queen
side with d3 and d5 by Magnus grabbing
more space in the center we have Knight
to g3 and now even be 5 so if Bobby
doesn't want to allow Magnus to have
complete control of the center of the
board he will capture F captures on e6
impose on Queen captures on e6 and now
Queen to f2 developing the Queen and
making room for the King to castle call
sand castles
we have castles by Fabia as well and
already you can see that the position
really resembles some some sort of weird
opening with Knight to g6 developing the
night and now efore attacking the center
we have D captures
for night captures and night the c-7
Bishop to h5 by Fabi and now Queen to d5
getting the Queen out of the way so now
you can develop the lights for a bishop
as well and also attacking the bishop on
age five
so here Fabi has to decide does he want
to capture and maybe continue
development with Bishop to f4 or play
Bishop Devery which he did now
threatening some very nasty discoveries
like Knight captures an f6 check which
would pick up the Queen
Magnus retreats we have Queen to d7 and
the now comes the knight back to g3 now
the bishop is on a very strong diagonal
with Knights the e6 by Magnus and now
Bishop the e4 centralizing the bishop
with the ship to c7 now continuing
development and Bishop to d2 probably
going for Bishop to c3 to get his Bishop
on this very nice diagonal we have
Bishop to b7 opposing Kiwanis lights
were Bishop Bishop captures with rook a
person b7 and now rugby t1 sort of
completing the development this Bishop
might still come to c3 we'll see how it
goes and now rook back to b8 he wants to
bring this rook over to a 8 and here
Fabi goes for rook to e4 probably to
gain more control over the f4 square he
doesn't want to allow any pieces jumping
to a4 and also it keeps an eye on the
sea for squares so it's sort of a
multi-purpose move but it also allows
crossing a very nice idea so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
very nice idea while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such a nice idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
f5 which is of course made possible
because the move comes with tempo the
rook on e4 is under attack
and now corona has to decide where he
wants to capture the pawn or go back
with the rook if you go back with rook
you can't have to admit the rook to e4
was a mistake but capturing isn't all
that much better if Knight captures an
f5 Knight eat f4 now opening up an
attack towards the night here and you
can't really move it if you move the
knight then this Knight comes to h3 with
Church and the rook picks up the Queen
so not an option you would have to play
Bishop captures and now after rook
captures on f5 there's now a triple
attack
towards the bush appear you would have
to defend it with g3 but now rugby tf8
Magnus would get insane development and
an attack you wouldn't be able to
capture on e4 at any point maybe put
even put g5 the attack would be
overwhelming for whites to control but
Fabi of course did not capture Fabi went
back with the rook with rook to e1 and
now rook beat yet by Magnus Magnus
doesn't want to be over adventurous with
f4 although it was possible at 494 and
now f3 really all hell just breaks loose
G captures now rook the f5 preparing to
bring the outlook over to f8 but it yeah
although it is a classical game is still
only 45 minutes and you don't get
increment there are no delays so you
don't have all that much time to
calculate rugby t8 by Magnus and now
rush up the c3 bringing it to this very
nice diagonal with Knight eat the f4 now
still Magnus reluctant to push f4 Bishop
back to be 2 now going back to d2 going
after the night and f4 and now rook
captures anyone real captures anyone by
Fabien de now Knight back to d5 now
again the f4 square is covered by both
nights and by the bishops oh and by the
rook when you push f4 so everything is
ready for the f4 thrust with c4 just
attacking the knight by pushing the
knight back 90 de7 and now comes d4
hoping to get this d5 move in but Magnus
now finally starts pushing the F pawn
with F for attacking the knight Knight
the f1 and now f3 so what do you do here
you could play g3 but it's gonna be this
point will not remain there for very
long
well you will not be able to capture it
back the rook nicely defends it and once
you play something like Knight to c6
capture with the pawn on d4 free d5
square foot and I get the night over to
g4 you can kick with the Queen from f2
maybe even pulled upon 2 f2 it's gonna
be very unpleasant
so Bobby decides to capture with G
captures on f3 and the now Knight to f5
bringing pieces closer to the White King
we have looked for now the rook helps
out with the defense of the
fourth-ranked and the nose
eeeek actress on d4 with nightcap for
Sundy for and not Knight to e5 again
bringing more pieces even closer to the
white king with nice to be five by Fabi
going after the bishop on c7 but now
Knights the H for a very nice maneuver
by Magnus point is you of course you
cannot capture because night after Sun
f3 chair picks up the Queen very nice
fork so after Knight to h4 with f4 by
Fabi and now Knight eat the f3 with
check with King to 8:1 and now we have
Queen to c6 and here you're putting the
Queen and this beautiful diagonal the
rook cannot move otherwise you get some
wonderful discoveries so what can you do
here the rook is under attack
Fabia's very long time here Magnus was
up on the clock some 10 minutes and
father was already closing in on that
one minute mark and it's only moved 31
they still need nine more moves to reach
time control so Bobby played Knight back
to c3 just defending the rook but it
doesn't work why it doesn't work
well you are here to decide that feel
free to pause the video and try to find
out why it doesn't work well I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding out why it doesn't work and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show its Knight to g5 and now it'll
make sense there's a double attack on
the rook you cannot move it as there's a
pin here so you know just you will lose
that rook
of course the ball the knife cannot be
captured because rook captures Queen so
everything is nicely pinned Bobby played
night 2 G 3 added another defender to
the rook here and here Magnus just
played Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures any for is a great move if it
wasn't then there was the even greater
Bishop to e5 which again you cannot
capture you cannot capture with this
because of rook captures Queen and now
you're threatening to remove one of the
defenders of the rook and then just to
grab a clean rook but luckily Knight
captures only for is is a is a
sufficient move so Knight G captures on
e4 and now comes Queen captures on c4 so
the White King is wide open there's not
much you can do here v played h3 I
wanted to make some more room for the
king and now Knight back to g6 piling
upon the f4 pawn with f5 but it's not
really a threat since the point was
still is unable to capture it we have
Queen to D 3 by Magnus going for Queen
captures on h2 recheck and now Bishop to
e3 Fabi defends it and here Magnus
played Bishop to e5 and it was in this
position unmoved 37 that Fabiana karana
resigned the game and Magnus takes the
lead in the match after losing round 1
then winning two games in a row so why
did you resign well you don't really
have a move and you are done done
material not so you could try Queen e2
to unpin for example threatened pawn
captures here but it's not a problem you
know Magnus just straights Queens and I
mean characters Knight captures now real
characters on f5 you are up upon and you
are up the exchange you have you have a
rope for Knights of course this will be
completely winning for Magnus so after
Bishop to e5 Fabi resigned and we go
into the other game I don't know if I
will have time to cover it today maybe
tomorrow but I will not spoil the result
for for anyone in this video so if you
want to know the result either check it
online or you will have to wait wait for
the next video but in a way today we are
done with with classical official random
games tomorrow we go into the rapid
Fisher random games and then into the
blitz fish random games and it's gonna
be very exciting to see who goes into
the finals of the world fish random
championship so uh that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank georgiana bronzy Nero Muhammad and
Mathias Mossman Carl Nielsen and
Alexander equivalent Co for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the this nice
coverage of the official random World
Championship continuing the coverage of
the European Team Championship if
there's a nice game or two and of course
checking up on your one for suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day